hello everyone this is the game of the
week the master Dennis boss
so this lecture we're going to talk
about the new rising star namely ali
reza fiducia and so one of the games
that which will be the high point of
this lecture is the famous and famous
game that was between Perugia and Kazem
well it was very interesting intense so
we're gonna take a look at that one but
first I was kind of curious myself
what makes fuchsias chess unique and in
fact if you know Michel Tao is his brand
of chess won't be that foreign to you so
let's start with his match that he
played in 2019 against Jorge quarry who
was 2700 GM he's still a very strong
grandmaster but in this match Perugia
showed how talented he is so let's take
a look at these games Steve for a 5 now
whenever you see Knight f6 e5 from a
2600 Plus Grandmaster you can already
sense that there must be an enterprising
player and indeed fuchsia as far as I
saw and you will see really likes to get
the initiative and go for the attacks
yeah this is the Budapest yes
he takes Knight g4 Knight f3 now the big
question is obviously what if Bishop f4
and this is considered fairly dubious
for black but Corey is not very well
known for playing the main lines he
likes to get interesting middle games
but is not that excited to get into
theoretical debates
so he goes Knight f3 Bishop c5
III knight c6 Knight c3 Castle rook e8
so far standard chess b3 but here again
fuchsia comes up with nice and very
unique way of playing let's try to find
that out what could have fuchsia played
here
so these six is the d6 is the casual
move that everyone would play but but
fear which is no more aiming for the
enterprising play close close
it's not b6 that we weigh b5 would be a
bit too enterprising so if I'd say that
this rook is going to show up on h6 I
wouldn't be lying yeah
a5 so just before you the viewers think
that the Budapest is not at all played
by top players that's not entirely true
in fact Mahmud Yara played it sometimes
in rapid chess and also most notably
Richard report beat gelfand with the
Budapest so it's a little bit underrated
it's still under pressure as I met [ __ ]
in the Bishop f4 line but it's still
playable
so now fuchsia is going for this
maneuver ok 6 for gage 6 with not a
single peaceful intention in mind we
should be to rue k-6 Queen d5 we should
be 7 now a piece is a piece he's not
going to give it for free we should pay
794 seemingly putting a lot of pressure
on black centre but fuel jet thinks
otherwise
you can't go rook rook e6 yes definitely
but that's not kind of the goal of your
play we're trying really hard to
checkmate don't ever lose the goal of
the game
checkmate ends at all yeah so it is
attacked twice
yes rue k6o you're giving up the night
but then so white actually didn't take
he took the pawn instead if you take
here I have this little sneaky move c6
and you can't really defend this bishop
no longer because this square is
defended I'm defending that pawn and
once your Queen moves or drops back to
the three I capture it and I still have
a big attack brewing so this yeah I
can't have both of my looks swinging
over exactly I could get my other rook
to h5 out I still have to tender that
bishop but it's not far-fetched you
could probably go rookie 646 in any case
Corey took on a five there should be six
and you'll never guess the best move in
this position
yes it's queen eight which looks totally
counter intuitive but the point is
otherwise this would be kind of brutal
still very strong but Queen a8 is kind
of fighting back these sexy five you've
got to find some counter chances Queen
h4 happens now also note that you have
to defend this rook at some moment you
can't really go and sack on h3 for
example if you go back here eventually
these h3 ideas could be facing some
these things Bishop takes h3 stuff now
probably I have to go after three
immediately because I have this double
thread though so Queen eight let's go
back to the game c5 Queen h4 Bishop
takes e5 de
but there's one defense here so know
that this night needs some protection
but also we don't want to get checkmated
and that's also a thing
hmm f3 defending both the night and I
mean you do give up that pun but you
don't get checkmated and you save the
night so that's kind of a good deal f3
takes rook g6 some more enterprising
play it's putting pressure on this pawn
now you could try to take here but then
the urge is gonna bulldoze you on the
second-ranked just take everything and
that be sad so Corey plays Ruby g1
Bishop d7 Queen age 3 Bishop Age 3
Bishop f1 so far
good good attacking play by black good
defense by white this is a critical
moment black needs to find the right way
to continue
ruk t8 yes so there's not much luxury
left in this position your bishop is
kind of saying his last prayers on b6
blood on the other hand that King
doesn't feel safe on after either f5 yes
let's go
typical thuja going all-in queen a4 and
another critical moment
yeah if you do have to turn for that
rook so in fact rook d8 was played and
it turns out it's a mistake in fact King
f8 would have been the best move and
then you can roll with the attack oh
wait a fee and you have a big attack
going but rook d8 surprisingly you'd
expect to be really good but the fact is
your king is just as weak as the white
one in fact it could get even even more
into more trouble
so check not that one actually no look
d1 d1 is very strong was spotted and was
very strong movement
you can't take because we say bye-bye
and screen a checkmate so you take and
it's me yeah
so it's an illusion that black is in
total control now Corey is actually the
one pressing here Luke f8 was good
Queen C 4 T gate shape and here Corey
misses a brilliant move
Kien f7 is actually the movie played
in fact the move is not g5
yeah it's it's unbelievable
rook takes g5 and the Queen drops all
the way to h4 and I'm just gonna take
everything so if you go rubgy sex I'll
take your a bishop first and I'm gonna
ask you how are you going to defend that
bishop and you're not able to because
hey I have some back rank ideas as well
also that a after I take on h3 exchange
Queens I'm up a piece I'm winning
so this was the fantastic idea that
Corey missed is that why can actually
sack a whole piece but because he
basically have a triple attack on blacks
pieces he's winning the game yeah
yeah
yes sit yeah yeah so Knight g5 it not
just threatens Knight f7 Knight takes h3
is also big threat yes so this would
have been the killer blow but Corey
missed it late Queen f7 rook g8 Nagi
five but now it's too late
takes takes and the attack is still
raging know that this King is kind of
safeguarding all of his guys but they
can't move at all
Queen c7 age six
rook d8 takes check takes King age seven
and here white resigned because he's
stuck and I'm still roaming down with my
pawns
now if white would try to go Queen B a
try to win the pot which is go clean
edge to attacking that g1 rook looking
f2 and I have this very nice move rook
g3 but the simple threat of rook takes
f3 Bishop c4 you think your mating your
think your mating no you're not takes
check and we say hello to the be a queen
so that's kind of the reason that
fuchsia on this game at that moment
after King h7 because it's very hard to
defend against this idea of taking rook
g3 and rook f3
now you can stay on f1 with your bishop
but then I'm just going to go rogue g3
rook F 3 and take on g1 and take
everything
so that was one typical fuchsia game
where he aggressively sacrificed
everything in one but how about a second
game in fact if you're watching this in
order this game was played before the
other game and again this is going to be
a d4 system so here it might plays this
interesting idea of night h4
this was a big idea some time ago but
has been analyzed these days be 5 d5 now
the knight can move to many places but
if we're getting familiar with fusion
style there would you post your knight
yes mm-hmm exactly
you will be looking for some aggressive
moves
if you go there I'll take that that's
still a piece so yeah yeah but that's a
piece sacrifice it's a bit early it's
still in the opening so I'll tell you
that in general Knight e5 is the typical
move but that's not aggressive enough
for ali reza he goes for the more
exciting night before immediately
counter attacking in the center efore
and you guess that c6 he's immediately
undermining wide center and he's trying
to get some play and hopefully open up
his bishop queen bee 393 Bishop e3 see
and the Knight f4
which way
a3 it would go night a6 yes yeah and
would go c5 and with e4 so a 3 here plan
is to go a knight c5 and 84 yes
so II force played c c6 93 and 94 if
you're actually familiar of it
mija halls games Wow at least for me
this reminds me of the boat v-neck tall
game where what's Vinick phased the
night F for peace sacrifice Bishop f3c
takes he takes the 5 g 5g f ef same
concept he's giving up a piece but he
says okay I'm going to roam down with my
pawns and I'm gonna check meet you so
taking the piece was correct EF the ship
takes b6 takes rook e1 so white is
saying okay go ahead take my night but
then I'll get active play so guess what
here's your plate here g4 no it's not
what he played he's trying to keep as
many pieces on the board as possible
uh-huh he played Bishop e5 now facing
attacks like this let's be honest is not
that easy because maybe at home you say
that oh if I play this long variation
I'm safe you don't get the luxury when
you're playing a live game you have to
calculate it yourself and you have to
decide between many tempting options so
Corey had to choose between going Knight
g2 and rook takes e5 and it turns out
that probably rook takes e5 wasn't as
good actually
like night Luke takes e5 here probably
Bishop e2 and Bishop b5 would have been
more accurate with chances of holding
but rook takes e5 rook takes e5 and so
what I've thought here that okay I'm
stabilizing I give up my rope for two
pieces that usually provides an
advantage for white but he miscalculated
to play Bishop e4 and now
pooja is going for the killer attack
of course f3
93
retexe b6
yes Rock age 5 so if I go to that night
f1 you have Queen age 3 and I'm getting
made it so my best shot is Queen c7 but
this runs into a spectacular move
so white is just a move away from
defending everything if the Queen
arrives on g3 it's done okay but if I
take exactly and then rook g5 so the g3
was the killer move and in fact it takes
this happened I mean okay Travis played
first g3 but the same old concept Knight
f1 he's trying to defend but the problem
is that Knight is not going to hold out
for too long so in general should we
close the position with black or should
we open it
of course we open it here we have the
rooks you want open files yep
GF is played because you want to have
some control over the G fund G 1 square
king H one rogue g5 setting up this
deadly idea of rogue g19 g3 Misha page 3
Bishop takes F 3 and now firoozeh to
move and win in glorious fashion
that is true but then white is still
fighting for his life we want to win
outright
just logical chess rook e8 yes rook e8
94 I'm blocking seemingly I'm holding
everything together well not so much in
reality takes c4 yes boom
so if Mischa p4 as hereafter will take
c4corey resigned now if I take with
night I have this beautiful one rook g1
takes takes and it's checkmate and you
just don't have enough defenders and
just get checkmate it in the back rank
but after Bishop takes c4 and there's
this beautiful finish
Knight takes e4
yes
and the ship G to check my beautiful
checkmate so as you can see future likes
to play with fire and he's really good
at it
mostly winning so the these were the two
games from the quarry fuchsia match and
this is pretty spectacular
I think and the other last two games I
want to show it was played in Moscow in
the Rapidan blitz World Championships
now the first one is played against
score above and the other one is against
Qasim so let's proceed with that one
Sofia as you might have guessed is an e4
player because he likes action and it
goes for the initiative now on the other
hand core above is more like a complex
player he doesn't shy away from fighting
chess but he likes strategic chess as
well
c5 and if you're familiar with core
above it was 90% chance there that is
going to be an either off and it is
indeed and I Dorf a6 Bishop g5 97 Bishop
c4 in fact core above later turn to e6
in his second game when he played here
in Moscow 97 ship c4 86
now I'm not a big fan of blacks play in
fact black is wasting a lot of time not
developing and just chasing the bishop
now future as we can see likes active
chests so did he even consider going
backwards
no so of course he took gonna have six
and he says okay I give up the bishop
pair but I'm going for a straight attack
in exchange that takes up six castles in
six there should be 3 game be one you
should be seven now let's stop right
here at the moment this is the
like a very normal classical night off
position so that white we have to decide
where we want to continue our play any
ideas where should we start playing and
trying to come up with an attack and
it's very important if whiteness plays
this part of the game and it's very easy
to get into dangerous territory
mm-hmm so yeah f4 f5 makes a lot of
sense because the black king is still in
the center so we can't really claim an
advantage if we start pushing our pawns
with after the g4 because there's no
guarantees that Coral Bob is going to
castle at all
yeah so you played it f4 and Luke H e1
in fact in some of my old games as well
white is threatening to do ideas of
Knight f5 sacrificing and opening it up
for the rook so no wonder Corbeau felt
ok it's due time to Castle before
anything funny happens I'm sure you
didn't
Wow he played rook c5 probably still
against potential sacrifices on f5 and
d5 Queen e2 just getting an extra piece
there to go E 5 that wasn't really
possible because the rook and Queen was
putting too much pressure on the e5
square Queen e2 castles so if we
prepared it we should play it and
fuchsia plays e5 de fe 9 8 7 and now
your real job to move and play
if you go 95 I mercilessly take you I
did I defend yeah but I take everything
in a flavor cap 7 defend my bishop on
you he said on the drug 95 I just take
or yeah but then I changed that a knife
look up 7 in the end yeah so 95 doesn't
really work here I just have too much
pressure on that square ah you're
talking about 95 here
well usually then you would get a really
bad structure for black that's why
you're trying to avoid it and you don't
even mind putting the night on 87
I mean you mind you wouldn't like to put
it there but it's better than 95 if I
play tidy 5 definitely your idea of
taking on the 5 and pushing that's
viable and it's pretty good
both quarter both played 9 8 7
yep of course both of these guys are
undefended so it's just logical that he
attacks both of them now if Whitewood
faci takes f5 that would be good news
because rook takes d7 and with dis
bishop having lots of pressure on that
at 7 square and this rook harassing all
those pieces and pawns this would be a
dream land for fuchsia simply queen d8
core above dead in d3 he's insistent he
still gives the option take please take
then I can take on these Sabbath
Roxy 7 and now fuchsia comes up with a
very nice move it shows how creative he
is in attacking chest
new people I mean sacking on the
kingside seems a little bit early
because we don't have enough pieces
there yet so fewer is kind of continuing
the same concept of harassing the pieces
on e7 and e7 just he does it in an
unusual fashion
so if you look at blacks position which
of black pieces apart from the h7 Knight
is misplaced and is a potential target
for tactics the d7 Bishop and a little
bit the Queen on d8 it's a little bit
too passive there in fact we could use
yes rook three four and that is the big
concept then after he takes I have rug
d4 and you can't really move the bishop
because I'll take your queen and if I
take on these seven that's clear
advantage as we talked about it
I haven't unopposed white squared bishop
on v3 and that's just advantage Fallujah
so Cora Bob is trying desperately to
avoid that there is Bishop c5 and
surprisingly I'll be honest with you
Knight d6 is crying out for myself alive
I don't want to play Knight d6 but
future for some reason plays Knight g3
and says okay I'm not in rush to do that
also note as this Bishop moved you can't
really move that Bishop because your
queen would be hanging so black needs to
waste some time but now peruzzo goes on
the attack
h4 it's trying to get rid of the screen
and in fact here core buff makes a
mistake should have played queen g6 and
trying to offer trades of some sorts
prevent queenie 7 but then we go on the
offensive not really group g4 but the
same idea of 9h v not h5 now and
suddenly we are swarming in with all our
pieces g6 Knight f4 note that there are
some nasty tactical tricks on g6 if you
would just play Bishop c6 boom and you
can't even capture back because the
whole time would be hanging
so Corrado plays rough g8 and even
though Fedora has a better position it's
not yet winning so if you don't have a
winning position yet don't forget to
improve your pieces and that's exactly
what fusion does here 94 exactly getting
the night into the center and attacking
this Bishop h5 but when the time is
right Fiona notes to strike yes
be careful that g6 square is still
heavily guarded so obviously the first
move as night h5g takes h5 rook takes
King takes
now there's a splendid tactical idea
that fusion spots
none of six I take windey eight
mm-hmm whether I would run away
uh-huh you started this you just rotate
the move order and it works so here man
King a chip if you go King f8 same idea
actually yeah it works this way six now
I can check you Bishop takes c6 if you
take I'll check you first and then just
take the Queen and the bishop
so if takes check here in fact okay this
is even prettier not that book things d8
is not winning this is also winning but
Queen f8 is a little bit more stylish
and F takes c6 just loses to f7 and
promotes Queen's double mates and
promotion so Carrabba was forced to play
King h8 but again that f6 the problem is
the same as you pointed out Queen j8
this come in
you can't go back because the d7 is
hanging and if you ever take then I have
the double threat of taking on c7 and
Queen g7 so to all intents and purposes
White is just completely winning here
Queen f8 97 Queen g7 are we excited to
exchange Queens now we were trying to
checkmate the guy Queen f3 Queen f1 it's
probably trying to maneuver back that
Knight to f6 Bishop F 2 C 3 and this is
a very nice little move creating lift
for the king the bishop is coming back
to the game
Queen h4 bishop c2 Nagi 5 finally the
night arrives on f6 and now we have
nasty ideas over the King stud also 98
and I take c7 is annoying rook c8 let's
play there for me
- so he actually just moved the Queen
back in order to avoid Queen trade but
normally he'd still like the Queen to be
closer to the king Bishop c5 Knight
takes h5 which should be 7 g3 just
chasing the Queen away from the H file
so we can attack it frontally Queen h3
night at four minutes six Queen g2 Queen
takes me seven and black resigned and in
view of rook e8 Bishop a4 as I have just
too many pieces attacking the rook and
the bishop so this is just completely
lost
so therefore horrible I resigned now
this was kind of an introduction of how
future plays and I think it'd still be
interesting to take a look at the game
that Bloods game that was pivotal for
the red bloods championship in Moscow
and that game was between cause and
Perugia and causal yes thank you
in fact if you look at the stars of
these two players cause they used to be
this outrageous attacking player in his
teenage years but he changed his style a
little bit it's a little bit more
circumspect more positional fuchsia is
still the young teenager who loves
attacking yes going for broke
it's very interesting how calls and
plays and what openings he chooses
against fuchsia so e4 e5 first sign that
he's going for the long haul
he's going for the long positional game
Knight f3 Bishop b5 by far the most
critical line a six and A six is also
showing that cousin is going for a game
he's not trying to play Knight f6 in the
Berlin he's going all out he wants to
have a fighting game we should pay for
in fact I heard that he gave an
interview before the game and said that
this game is going to be legendary d6
Castle Bishop d7 G 6 so now he kind of
entered this Steinitz variation and
what's exciting about this choice is
that Colin is trying to get into more of
a strategical battle against fuchsia d4
Bishop g7 h3 and it kind of works in
some aspects as Perugia is aiming to get
active piece play usually according to
the theory d5 should be the best move
ninety seven takes takes Bishop e3 h6
92 f3 c4 and this is considered to be an
advantageous Kings Indian like position
but fuchsia is not as familiar with d4
openings
he's more of an e4 player and this could
eventually lead to a more slower
strategic game
Sophia probably consciously avoids that
and goes h3 9 f6 Bishop c2 rook e1 and
this is kind of funny and probably the
best pairings in chess whenever two
Styles Clash whenever you see a
tactically gifted player play a
positional player those are usually very
exciting rook e8 92 so you can see that
fuchsia sticks to the plan of keeping
this position dynamic Queen e7 but also
you can see that causing is happy to
maneuver in the back rank Knight f1 and
if you look at this position from the
blacks perspective which piece is the
most awful one if you if you could
pinpoint that that black would be happy
to give away or exchange it away
well the c69 not that much just defense
there there's not not many things not
much that we could do with it at the
moment maybe in the future maybe in the
future but Nitin Nohria in the moment
these seven no we I mean this Bishop
even though it looks passive it's still
very important in this Kings Indian type
of structure
so whenever white would decide to go d5
this would be very important in the
attack
it's mostly the King's Indian like
Bishop on g7 that black would like to
get rid of you can't really do anything
with it so Carson comes up with a plan
trying to exchange this one off
yeah King a Jim Nagi is another way of
playing and with Bishop h6 he goes on in
place Queen after eight same idea but he
also gets out of the way and stuff so
now g3 Bishop h6 now I kind of like
fusions reaction he says okay you want
to exchange off the bishops now yeah if
this was a friendly game I would
exchange but this is not a friendly game
so I'm gonna keep my Bishop thank you
and now comes game plan number two black
will try to get rid of that man on g5
and that can only be done with some
maneuvering and if you ask Colin he's
ready to maneuver
so how could we exchange this night off
possibly
yeah I said exchange it off yes uh-huh
98 so this looks like a very funky move
it's very rare I rarely see this idea
and in fact they think the Arusha should
have played d5 here because then this
night would feel a little bit awkward on
the 8 on the other hand we do get into
positional and strategic play but I do
feel that this night would be so
misplaced that might should be somewhat
better in this King zinnia like position
now he doesn't play d5 he plays Bishop
b3 96 and would feel shy like exchanges
nah no h4 rook the eighth and he plays
Bishop e3 in fact Knight f5 would have
been an interesting idea
yeah yeah so takes takes and then there
would be some pressure on the f7 square
yeah yeah that game D Corrigan yes so
this was an interesting idea probably is
just interesting but feverish is being
conservative here played Bishop III now
calls and notices that Knight f5 is
looming in the air so it decides to go
back to g7 and that is kind of the sense
of danger you need to become a really
good player once you spot your opponent
has a big big idea you move away from
the threat h5 Bishop h6 and again this
is kind of funny he goes back as he sees
that once you move the pawn you don't
have a defender so now this night on g5
is a little bit more loose so here you
play the Queen c1 but probably there
were some ideas of Queen f3 and if black
takes takes Knight takes Queen takes f6
it's roughly even with black having play
on the Kings side it's still a
complicated game but definitely Queen f3
was an option probably I think that
Queen f3 would have been a better choice
Queen c1 but I think fuchsia here missed
Carlson's next move
he probably thought that there's just
too much pressure on the 86 bishop he
has night II 6 ideas this should be good
for him but it turns out it's not the
case yes exactly not g4 and suddenly the
hunter gets hunted and the Queen
actually will have chances to invade and
set up some mating ideas Knight takes c6
f takes c6 and again the problem is for
white you can't really take because
Queen f2 Queen g3 and I win the house
takes take and not only I have an extra
pawn I also have mating threats so at
this moment fuchsia is down on the clock
this is a blood game if you didn't know
and calls them Marcelle fault in being
in the driver's seat
Brooke f1 this is actually peculiar move
at first sight I didn't like this rook
f1 move Knight f2 is that Bishop is
still hanging probably Bishop takes c3
is the one that's really threatened rook
f1 and I think here Carlsen made a rash
decision I think he wanted to make sure
that he has an advantage for short but I
think he should have taken on e3 with
the bishop and go either create 6 or
Queen e7 did the idea of invading with
Queen h4 and get your pieces in and just
go for the attack but probably Carson at
this moment felt that ok if I take on e3
Fe Queen e7 there's no way
could be any trouble that's what he
thought each takes Queen d2 but now
future is going to put up some stiff
defense Queen d2 this was a very good
move connecting the two rooks also you
know coming closer to the Kings side
making sure that that night we'll have a
safe defender he takes see takes
probably takes is also a little bit
dodgy but I could understand cause in
here because he's trying to win this
game and he's sure that he has the
advantage he has the bishop pair and
these that so that night is on on g30
miss plays then has a V King so it is
just logical to take on d4 C takes d4 on
the other hand it kind of improves bikes
pieces a little bit King g7 rook f3 and
this is a really good move defending
this weakness and stabilizing the knight
on F on g3 look at faith look f1 takes
takes look at faith being c3 and
suddenly where the rooks exchanged off
white is not much worse anymore in fact
he's putting a lot of pressure on the
King there's some d5 ideas sometimes and
if you make the wrong pawn pushes this
Bishop will get really active c6 Knight
f1 so the computer kind of suggests
ideas of a5 but note that there they
only have minutes at this point so II
five is very very tempting but can be
double-edged if it's bad it's really bad
so he goes Knight f1 he's just trying to
stabilize he five and probably e5 and
this is the turning point from this on
is gonna be fuchsia who is going to be
pressing rook takes a faith King takes
f8 Queen c4 and
suddenly it is white who's attacking
because this Knight is defending the
only weakness on e3
and this battery is just very powerful
and note that these pawns are not
entirely protected Queen f6 but this was
a make big mistake in our usha to move
and take advantage
Sood assume that there's some drama on
the kingside but the trick is the drama
is not on the Queen on the kingside it's
actually on the other side of the border
yes dee takes e4 e5 and instead of Queen
g8 stuff the rich black could very
easily queen bee forecheck and suddenly
the phone is dropping c5 green takes v7
Bishop b5 CA check and in fact this is
the moment when cousin was really upset
with himself and he even physically
should it at the board which is
understandable if you look at it he had
a stable advantage and suddenly he's
down to pawns so it's clearly it's not
going the way he expected it to be Queen
d6 Queen takes King takes d6 Bishop f7
Bishop takes f1 g5 now technically this
looks winning and should be winning but
to set up the scene Perugia was getting
really nervous he was kind of moving
around in like dropping pieces on the
other hand cousin just messed up his
winning position and remember this is
move 40 by now they're down two seconds
so they're around ten eight and ten
seconds at this moment kingi to Bishop
f8 GD 7 so far good play by fuchsia he's
winning he's not rushing as we've
learned that recently fixes the pawn on
g5 and that's just perfect and now it's
time to create another pastor Bishop d8
before also note how calls in defense he
built a fortress or sort of a fortress
and he's not making any commitments
she's waiting for Perugia to decide how
he's keep he trying to go forward takes
takes Bishop e7 b5 Bishop d8 King g6 and
suddenly Carson has to make a decision
so he goes king c5 decides to take this
pawn in a five takes king c5 king g6
Bishop a5 b5 Bishop d2 and in fact a
thing this was the critical moment now
if you've seen the videos and their many
videos out there of this game and this
moment future has around I think five
six seconds so he still could make a
decision the situation is tense and in
fact that is why it's so important to
have composure when you're playing the
game of chess because sometimes the best
moves are not the most logical ones so
it's white to move and that would have
won the game
you have seven if I take the bishop
yes
exactly so e4 was played by king f7
would have won the game and to be honest
that's why it's important to keep calm
because King f7 is by no means the most
logical move why would you give up your
bishop or pawn when you could keep all
the pawns on the board and it's very
interesting if you look at it with the
computer
efore is plus 2 meaning white is up just
two pawns king f7 is plus 10 so the most
yes so yes so II for even the most
logical move it is not even entirely
clear if fuchsia is winning after that
move but after kink f7 this would be a
win the only thing that he would have
needed to make sure that he has one
extra pawn and in the end he's going to
collect the g5 pawn and then just
promote that the King can't really take
both of those you'll take the e pawn
I'll take the G and then I just go and
rush my Jeep on up and win and after you
for and as the computer points out this
position is not that easy to win and by
now they'll be just rushing the moves
King c7 and now calls and builds up this
fortress which is not that easy to break
at all g5 King g4 and after Bishop d2 as
we all know huge I ran out of time here
now there was the controversy and there
was an appeal Jerusha appealed that this
shouldn't be considered a win but
according to the federal regulations if
there is a position that you could set
up and that would be possible to
checkmate in that case then
it's a win for the side who has the last
pieces no no probably some so I'm not
sure if that is the best rule on the
planet but it does make some sense in
the case that if there would be some
extra pawns you could imagine that Y
could lose and also I think there were
some increments as far as I know at this
tournament so fusia just needed to make
more moves not to run out of time on the
other hand I do understand I mean if you
ask a master a grandmaster you wouldn't
believe that Y could lose this but
according to the feeder rules this is a
win for black if white flags yeah yeah
if the King would be set up in the
corner that would be the theoretical win
for black but obviously that wouldn't
happen so in fact the reason I thought
it's interesting to show this game is
that fuchsia was playing really well but
then he got nervous by the end and
instead of trying to go for broke and
try to go for the best move and I do
understand you're you have four seconds
left and you're playing the world
champion but if he gets that composure
in the future probably is going to be a
great contender for the title and in
fact this was a very important game
after this one cause and managed to
clinch both the world blitz championship
title both the world blitz and the bird
world rapid championship title so this
was a very critical game for his blitz
match and
chances so I hope you guys enjoyed this
lecture on ferocious chest and you can
see he has this very attractive
aggressive style but if he will have
extra composure probably he'll be
someone to be dealt with and he is going
to play in January and be conse so don't
miss him is going to be very interesting
the that thank you so much for watching
thank you
[Music]
you